action
okay so everyone I'm read it as saying
that Daenerys and Yara are totally gonna
get together they're just gonna have
Danny marry John probably I bet Daario
is just gonna sneak on the ship or
something they don't call it King's
Landing for nothing
Jordan too soon I told you they were
gonna confirm the fan theory we still
don't even know when we honest said
tonight what do you know what she said
okay Faris can clearly teleport I mean
you gotta have a little bit of
suspension of disbelief yeah if I were
as bold as that little eight year old
mormont girl maybe Carl would it give
him your raise oh I forgot Duran is
coming over for a joint you're in do you
watch Game of Thrones yeah but I haven't
seen tonight so you'll spoil it for me
you didn't have to yell at her well she
is a social responsibility not to come
into our home and try to make idle
conversation when she hasn't even seen
the episode I mean just some [ __ ]
nerve
well at least NFL SUNDAY start in eight
weeks you want to just start the show
over from season one mids there now John
Oliver is going to be off for a month to
do this